le président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines en maître d'hôtes ce
22 mai jean michel fourgous républicain
présentait audrey pulvar socialiste le
dispositif en place depuis plusieurs
mois au sein du vélodrome national situé
à montigny le bretonneux ici plus de
cent trente mille personnes ont été
vaccinées contre la colite 19 moi je
suis un élu républicain
et bien entendu c'est de voir tous les
gens qui participent à la vie politique
donc c c'est le rôle de chaque élu bien
entendu de montrer qu'on écoute tout le
monde et qu'on est con rencontre et
qu'on montre bien sur ce qui marche à
tous les élus dans les allées du
vélodrome audrey pulvar a ainsi
rencontré médecins infirmiers en
souhaitant une accélération du
calendrier maxime je me réjouis qu'une
grande partie des adultes franciliennes
et franciliens puissent soit souvent a
déjà vaccinées soit en cours de
vaccination et je crois que maintenant
l'urgence ça va être d'ouvrir la
vaccination aux 16-18 ans un peu plus
tôt dans la journée la délégation de la
candidate à la présidence de la région
s'est aussi rendu à mantes la jolie pour
évoquer cette fois ci les transports et
sa proposition phare la gratuité pour
tous la problématique principale sur le
département c'est avant tout d'être sur
une un renforcement en fait de la diète
des transports qui crée une inégalité au
sein de nos territoires on sait très
bien que nous avons aussi bien des
territoires ruraux que des territoires
urbains assez dense que les gens ont du
mal à se déplacer
une visite dans les yvelines somme toute
assez calme quelques heures plus tard
débutait une autre séquence hautement
plus polémique le ministre de
l'intérieur entend déposer plainte
contre audrey pulvar l'accusant de
diffamer la police cette dernière entend
bien lui rendre la pareille en
l'attaquant pour dénonciation
calomnieuse
une rencontre entre les deux
protagonistes pourraient avoir lieu pour
calmer la situation
à moins d'un mois du scrutin régional